deep under europa's thick icy surface
lies an ocean larger than all of earth's
oceans combined
but it's pretty useless way out there
let's ship that water back to earth
how would you be able to mine the water
from under all that ice
how long would this whole expedition
take
and
would this water even be drinkable
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we brought europa's ocean
water to earth
even though it's slightly smaller than
our own moon scientists theorize that
beneath its frozen surface could be
nearly twice as much water as on earth
most of what we know about this moon is
from information gathered by the galileo
spacecraft but europa has been visited
by four other spacecrafts as well
the journey to europa is a long one it's
located five times further away from the
sun than earth
with our current technology a space
probe could reach this moon within three
years
but if you want to send a ship with a
crew of astronauts to mine collect and
transport water back home
you're gonna need a lot more time
europa's waters are intriguing but
nothing is as dire as the oceans back
home
climate change has been raising
temperatures around the globe and now
ice glaciers are melting and raising sea
levels
what's worse carbon dioxide dissolves
over oceans and creates a process called
acidification
this deadly chemical change destroys
coral reefs and forces the fish that
live there to migrate somewhere further
north
our actions have consequences and it's
great to reduce your personal carbon
footprint but now's the time to
encourage lawmakers and manufacturers to
stop using so much fossil fuel it
doesn't matter if it's a server farm or
an olive grove we all have to stop
emitting so much deadly co2 into the
atmosphere
progress has to start at the top let's
work together to get lawmakers to create
the infrastructure we need to lay out
the path to the future and support
businesses that reduce their carbon
emissions remember your dollars have as
much power as a nasa rocket
[Music]
you've been waiting decades for this
moment
nasa is finally ready to send a large
spacecraft to europa and you'd be on
board
getting your big ship out to jupiter's
icy moon would require you to get a
little boost
using a gravity-assist flyby technique
you'd pick up some additional speed by
swinging past venus or mars on the way
with this technique you'd be borrowing a
bit of momentum from these planets own
orbits around the sun
you'd slingshot your ship out of their
orbit at a faster speed than you entered
it or slower in case you're on track to
zip past your destination
when you arrive at your destination the
first thing you'd notice when you
stepped out of your ship would be
oh how cold it is
near europa's poles temperatures could
be as low as minus
223 degrees
and it would be dark
here you'd only be getting four percent
of the sunlight you'd be used to back on
earth
but you'd be dazzled by the pulsating
green light of the icy surface
this glow-in-the-dark effect would be
thanks to jupiter constantly drenching
europa in high-energy radiation
and jupiter would be almost 24 times
larger in the sky than our moon is to us
it would be time to drill through the
ice and this would be hard work
in order to reach the water below you'd
have to drill deeper than the deepest
hole ever drilled on earth
the cola super borehole in russia goes
down 12.2 kilometers
on europa you'd need to go twice as far
and this could take you a while
scientists in antarctica drilled there
at a rate of about one meter every six
minutes
it took them three days to reach a depth
of 730 meters
now scientists estimate that europa's
ocean could have a depth of between 60
and
150 kilometers
that would make it almost 14 times
deeper than earth's challenger deep the
almost bottomless pit of the mariana
trench
after all this travel and work you'd
finally be able to take a sip of this
ice cold extra-terrestrial water for the
very first time
but you'd spit it out pretty fast it
would taste a lot like ocean water back
on earth
yeah maybe you better check its
composition now before loading it up for
the trip home
based on europa's surface and rocky
interior this water would likely have a
mix of magnesium sulfate and sodium
chloride
in other words epsom salt and table salt
yeah this water would undoubtedly make a
more relaxing soak in the tub after all
that drilling
in order to drink it you'd need to
desalinate it first
this process would freshen it up enough
to quench your thirst
[Music]
this expedition would be too expensive
an adventure to return home empty-handed
the uncrewed eight-year galileo mission
to study jupiter cost about
1.39 billion dollars so the price tag of
your mission would be well
astronomical
would it have been easier and cheaper to
just desalinate our planet's ocean water
well no time to worry about that now
you'd load up your ship with as much
water as it can carry and get ready for
the long journey back to earth
as you look out on europa's glowing
surface getting further and further away
you'd remember that your spacecraft is
loaded with water from another celestial
body and you didn't even think to look
for signs of biological life
time to turn that ship around and look
for aliens
but
that's a story
for another
what if